[Musique]
didier wampas bonjour madame merci
d'avoir accepté cette interview vous
êtes didier wampas du groupe les wampas
voilà on est sur la scène de la batterie
à guyancourt belsen belles scènes qui
vous plaît beaucoup beaucoup génial moi
je trouve ça va et vous êtes en début de
tournée ouais
votre dernier album est sorti il ya pas
longtemps on a envie de dire le 12
février
tu me dis si je le dis c'est que c'est
vrai voilà qui s'appelle évangélistes il
rentre juste eu du mal à jouteurs de 7
on y reviendra voilà d'accord le premier
il ya 30 ans à peu près s'appelait tutti
frutti
depuis on a eu 12 à peu près voilà et
l'avant dernier s'appelait les wampas
font la gueule alors ça va mieux
en plus l'accueil patricia les gars on
m'a posé la question bon deux ont pour
effet la gueule j'ai fait un nouvel
album on posera plus la question on pose
encore la question mais aussi l'âme
travail mais pas la gueule ça va mieux
c'était pour il faudra traduire cela
valait mieux sera très content on est
très content dans cette course du
concert touche à tout va mais bon vous
allez immigrés alors y paraît je suis
parti à 7 way est un tonitruant à
nouveau du zodiac a ouvert la voie et
vous l'avez suivi
non je poursuive il rejoint partie web
on n'aime pas suivre super et pourquoi
cette voie parce que quitte à quitter
paris autant les au bord de la mer ouais
quitte à l'ouganda mais autant que du
soleil mais pas trop de patrons de
fachos si possible donc c'était bien
c'était bien alors ok donc evra gesti
sait qui c'est mon album
ces noms de l'album c'est long ajoute
heures de s'élever à 7 en juillet et au
mois d'août ya là à la saint-jean il ya
une grande fête à nier les outils mais
ils sont souvent ne s'est pas un bateau
avec des rameurs et des gens des
jouteurs avec delos c'est sûr tomber à
l'eau sont valables comme ça ça fait mal
il ya tout tout un folklore tout les
gens evangelisti c'était un peu une
légende des joutes et l'a gagné 5,6 fois
ça le bonhomme il fait 200 kg est un
visiblement voulais pas qu'ils gagnent
éliminé ajustements et j'étais là la
révolte et je suis déjà plus l'album
évangéliste tic par pour le venger et il
est content du contenu ou quoi ouais bah
oui quand même
ouais génial comme de soi qu'il ouvrait
son la ville si tu le croises dans les
routes c'est toi qui n'es pas content
oui oui ça peut faire mal
d'accord dans cet album ouais
évangélistes il ya plusieurs chansons un
petit peu énigmatique
selon bat souvent souvent tous les dieux
oui oui oui il y en a qui sont cons
comprend reprend le thème y en a
d'autres on se pose des questions
alors ce petit garçon roux l'a
traumatisé c'est quoi cette histoire
j'ai par contre chaque mètre était
traumatisée par un petit garçon assez
justement son jeu par le soleil au broad
ont pas sur une histoire comme ça et
après aux boîtes de sucettes fruits
justement comment vous baisser quand
viennent les idées parce que c'est vous
qu'êtes j'écris pas trop j'ai pris pas
trop des fois je vous dis deux idées sur
les carnets mais pas grand chose et
c'est en studio que j'ai presque
toujours tout ça comme ça chez les
chansons d'abord liée aux trébéens au
walhalla matthew à la maison at il dit
après je vais faut faire des maîtres des
paroles et je suis en studio j'ai des
idées ou pas et après faut voir avec des
paroles là dessus ouais d'accord voilà
faut que ça voulait dire que c'est pas
évident baby watine l'eau après que tu
mettes des paroles ça veut dire quelque
chose que ce serait bien mais c'est donc
là c'est parti d'une semaine sont nés du
chat un mouchoir d'accord ça va mieux
aussi
ouais ça a vu maman il était au creux
quatre chalets à l'époque de la pâte et
ça va mieux depuis qu'ils mangeraient
pas dit non ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
voilà patricia dans ce sens c'est la
bouffe il à la bouffe web etc ça
et cette patricia qu'on voit là c'est
une femme de thoniers sétois
ainsi paris france dans le clip mai
sinon on se parle marie-france l'égérie
la fameuse joris la fameuse main ouais
ouais
l'égérie de nuit parisiennes font et qui
habite à cet élan selon patricia lancé
c'était du nombre vendeuse chez franprix
pantin voilà donc c'est un jeu de rodez
quoi c'est une histoire passée un
hommage à kraftwerk chanson voilà ça
c'est un concept qui se mélangent qu'ils
se rencontrent non et à larreule il aura
pour tout décollage un peu aidé
connaissent je ne prétends pas que l'est
les deux mannequins dans les bacs un
sens
les trains qui partait pour berlin
les hommes machines au patricia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans fard
et on modèle
j
demis
faire tourner
[Applaudissements]
et suce ma roue alors ces civils et a ou
pas je peux dire c'est ma part danser
dans le vélo nice à sucer la roue de
quelqu'un c'est quand tu roules derrière
tu prends pas le tube tu vas je vais
devanture est derrière pour ton âme soit
igm en six ans on se fait pas chier
voilà c'est déjà bien c'est le romancier
péruvien mais qu'est ce que vous êtes un
fan de vélo oui n'est qu'un le vélo j'en
ai fais quand je peux quand j'ai le
temps
et bah alors justement pourquoi avoir
continué à mener deux carrières de front
après avoir travaillé et musiciens oui l
air est épais toulon-la posséderait le
monde se pose à qui j'aurais pas ce que
parce que j'ai pas envie c'est pas
rigolo si c'est ton métier de sur de la
musique c'est comme tous les métiers que
c'est un métier tu te lèves le matin
petit bossu il ya des gosses et le
quartier web si tu gagnes ta vie avec sa
douce et posée par pour gagner payer son
loyer trouveront en studio
ces 40 cachet france j'avais pas vu
rentrer là dedans je pense que je
comptais sa liberté jean louis je fais
des chansons que j'ai envie je m'en fous
pas mal de vous faire virer puis à la
maison de disque que je m'en fout quoi
c'était ça oui c'est la liberté la
liberté et à montreuil dans le l'autre
côté ratp j'avoue aussi la liberté mon
fils est un diamant
les indiens zut et j'avais une promo
j'étais plusieurs stades technicien la
ratp quand je suis parti all away le
plus vieux ce que tout le monde la promo
run technicien technicien supérieur
maîtrise cadres
moi je restais 30 ans technicien était
pluvieux de la régie joie plus attaqué
aux prud'hommes mais bon je vais pour
faire des choses à faire
d'accord et j'ai lu où j'ai entendu je
sais plus vous disiez c'est pas moi qui
suis rebelles sont les autres qui sont
des moutons de forme dû vous être belge
se rebellent de rien du tout j'essaie de
vivre ma vie normale - sur ce que j'ai
envie c'est pas compliqué parce que
j'aimerais vraiment mais c'est pas
compliqué de faire ce qu'on aime le seul
truc c'est sait tous que cette question
d'argent quand les stars les gens sont
bloqués il faut un métier de journaliste
eut pas ça pour toi et les autres pas
parler de ce qu'ils veulent parce que
leur direction veut pas ils ont peur de
se faire virer et enfin tout est comme
ça quoi les hommes politiques n'osent
pas plein je pense de dire vraiment ce
qu'ils pensent et faire vraiment
programme qu'ils ont envie parce que
s'ils ne seront pas élus enfin c'est que
les trucs comme ça quand tout le monde
voilà les groupes de rock qui font quoi
mais ils ont trouvé une petite case et
ben ils restent dans leurs petites cases
parce que d'un seul la famille fabre 40
cacher pour être atteint 8 enfants tu
vois c'est pas bien et alors pourquoi
vous dites n'est pas normal devant des
millions de disques
parce que c'est pas très sage trouvera
dans la société c'est pas très loin
c'est plus comme c'est pas normal que 40
personnes au nom soit aussi riche que
trois milliards de fois c'est la même
chose c'est une question de répartition
voilà d'argent elle normal qu'il dit 50
milliardaire qui gouverne la planète
c'est pas normal qu'il ya dix groupes
qui vont à millions d'albums et que les
autres galère tu vois ce serait mieux
qu'il ya 1000 groupes qui vont de 1000
albums que un groupe qui vont un million
c'est plus un accord voilà ça fait
quatre mille personnes ce lundi voilà
mille journalistes qui gagne voilà
moyens plutôt que quelques-uns qui voit
là tout se passe au mieux à voile
et c'est pour ça que vous êtes allé aux
états unis pourquoi ce que j'aime bien
je vais aller aux états unis parce que
c'est le seul pays où t'as pas
l'impression d'être d'arrivée que ton
argent il est là touristes toi y'a pas
cette relation que c'est toi tu veux en
afrique ou en asie où c'est toujours
gênant décalage d'un décalage cette fois
qui est plus riche la bosse chez toi qui
as un immigré qu'on regarde
hamon j'aime bien cette sensation
thermique dans des bars ou dans des
stations-service tournante au regard
doux venez d'où parler quelle langue
c'est vrai c'est le seul pays au monde
déjà où tu vas où mais j'avais vu de
touristes 99% et c'était unités dont on
est brassée par les touristes regardent
avec des gros yeux on vient de dire mais
vous venez de monsieur parler quelle
langue qu'est ce que vous faites la fin
c'est rigolo
évidemment plus à la stèle aux cases
voilà où c'était que pour ça bon c'est
pas que pour sa beauté l'occasion
d'aller se promener de manifester à tout
vendre c'est en france qu'il faudra
aller manifester bientôt la sueur mais
moi je ne sais pas quel score que non
d'accord et alors on explique cette
longévité qui ne paraît pas mais qu'ils
ont fait je suis pas vouloir arrêter ce
n'est pas compliqué tout à l'heure il
n'y a pas de question d'argent c'est
beaucoup plus simple tout est plus
simple on fait ce que l'on vit au fond
de la musique on s'éclate on fait les
chansons on est heureux de faire des
chansons enfin heureux d'avoir des gens
qui viennent voir heureux de des gens
qui écoutent tandis que s'ils sont pas
des millions est en vie le partager avec
des gens en vie de femme un minimum d
public un bien drôle hein il suffit que
de faux sang ok c'est pas il faut s'en
moquer on va pas jouer tout seul c'est
pas grave si on s'en moque les gens il y
plus d'un mois ils finissent pas venir
et c'est ça qui les attire ouais c'est
le sait pas mais c'est d'une certaine
liberté je prends les gens se rend
compte de ce à quoi
d'accord et alors qu'est ce qu'être vous
avez un nouveau set 5-1 dans le groupe
dont un petit nouveau
photo efe ok quel âge il ya 27 ans je
crois qu est ce qui l'a attiré chez vous
moi je vois qu'il ya après je la guitare
avec les grands parce que j'avais 15 ans
est venu voir les wampas et puis il a
appris qu on est tous les disques par
coeur ils avaient besoin de la
guitariste et on connaissait c'était un
pote qui s'occupait du site web permet
d'y tirer un pâté un fan
voilà donc les jouets à gonfler ses fans
au groupe egmont fut sauce et voies de
fait c'est un groupe aussi avec lui
qu'elle est fellow les extraterrestres
d'accord l'extraterrestre fils c'est mon
fils les crises appel il s'appelle
arnold d'où vient ce soir 2 il a joué ne
revient pas je viens et gardez pas poil
il est mignon et alors comment par
exemple parce que moi j'ai un fils de 20
ans pour raconter un peu ma vie il vous
connaît pas comment vous décrire comment
à à des gens qui vous disent rien de
forte demande
j'en sais rien c'est vrai on s'en fout
si une eau qui veulent venir ils
viennent s'ils veulent pas venir il sent
pas voilà oui mais vous déjà quand
j'étais môme on demandait d'expliquer je
sais pas comment expliquer un mec qui
fait du jazz j'aurais dit oui je m'en
foutrais fatwa c'est à toi de faire la
démarche aux fans des marchés tu aimes
un jour où tu aimes pas et même si si
l'homme poste intéresse pas j'en sais
rien mais devient il plus payer s'ils
veulent écouter des disques uni en
concert le 6 novembre puis continuez à
écouter de justin bieber puis voilà oui
d'ailleurs un qui déprime voilà mais du
coup quand même je trouve qu'il ya des
choses qui vous caractérise justement
cette sincérité cet honnête voiles et
j'ai pas envie de
dubai de vendre mon truc et le faire de
la pub comme tout le monde je m'en fous
j'ai pas mes disques et de faire la pub
allez-y non mais je parle pas avec toi
enfin pour essayer de vendre plus de
disques toi je m'en fous j'ai pas mais
voilà je dis rien au genre puisque vous
voulez pas moi je dis je continue sur
mon idée voici la même caractérisée par
cette liberté de parole
voilà chirac en prison le portefeuille
de manu chao
vous osez dire les choses cash dire oui
pour les parades chéri non plus enfin tu
vois où les ou non monsieur charles et
blum et à peu aux factures on est comme
on dit vous voilà quand même oui ça
dénote pas ou est ce que tout le monde
oui oui un petit peu mais bon j'ai en
tout cas vous vous écrivez vous composez
le jeu pour l'impression que j'ai
toujours j'ai pas l'impression d'être un
anarchiste ou d'un violent ou quelqu'un
qui dit des conneries là je dis ce que
j'ai envie c'est tout valence est pas un
mouton
je prends un bouton qu'est ce que c'est
ou non et comment vous débrouiller pour
travailler alors avec 2 7 3 à paris bon
on répète plus trop où ça va avoir été
trois fois par semaine pendant presque
15 20 ans le répéter trois fois par
semaine et après le batteur et partir à
la montagne ont répété moi puis après
tony parti à 7 ont répété encore moi il
me le répètent plus un but que voilà un
peu plus voilà totalement dans un
instant dans spontanée voilà un succès
nous on apprend une chanson sur scène
auront studio chaque concert est une
surprise voilà il n'a pas de pareil on
essaie de nous parce que pour l'instant
on essaie de ne pas se tromper de jean
de florette nouvel album ouais donc on
essaie de ne pas se tromper dans les
accords qu'est-ce qui va y avoir comme
chanson comme vieilles chansons si ce
pétrole on joue tous les tubes entre
guillemets un petit chez manu chao les
bottes rouges
voilà on fait plus la nouvelle juste
toutes les nouvelles bon et là vous êtes
parti pour nous contourner a très bien
france dont il ya de la place et les
gens veulent de nous ouais vous jouez
vous à part la france pour l'instant que
en france cette tournée du fauve en
suisse ou en belgique mais maintenant
ils disent que c'est même plus en suisse
et en belgique alors c'est triste bah
c'est l'europe doit faut fouiller gyms
et puis voilà faut faire l'europe des du
rock'n'roll d'accord bon bah voilà
non mais pour l'instant je me pense
puisque dans celui-ci voulait plus de
nous ce qu'on a fait une chanson une
fois j'avais dessous des irlandais
voulaient plus nouveau présent pas prêt
si l'on part ils ont pu établir si cet
hivelin peut-être les fesses du belge
peut-être qu'ils vont apprécier plus je
pense que vu que les fesses des belges
ok mais une chance le prennent mal tout
ou rien oui voila je tenais outre sans
rien à perdre
voilà le comte l'euro devrait aimer je
pense cette chanson est dédiée au prince
laurent spéciale dédicace prince laurent
bonbonnes tournée merci didier
merci à vous ciao
[Musique]